yeah here we go against mr. williger's
yeah I don't have a huge huge choice i'm
playing the kingside shadow week here so
here we go let's let's just play in that
typical a funky style of the kingside
fianchetto okay as usually just takes
everything that's inside yeah I have um
I have played this kind of thing against
him earlier I think I try to be quick of
course I know that I know the story lost
too many gains the game games against
him one time and those completely
uneventful end games to spend much time
here yeah the bad thing I think about
the position is I'm somewhat worse sorry
I'm somebody worse I been but sorry
about that ah 94 that was my idea not
sure if it is helping much but let's do
that
maybe six sent him send him back yeah
white is just a bit better yeah yeah the
bishop pair is nice maybe I could have
played night at five actually that would
have been interesting not not only
interesting but maybe also also better
um okay but still is this bad there
might be five is an annoying move maybe
em it's not not the nicest thing ever
let's do it neither five was much better
and then aged five but the playing quick
mode I really got to me yeah here why
this better of course and it's exactly
the position that he wants this kind of
thing where you can play a gazillion
moves and don't risk anything this
Bishop on d5 it's just better than my
bishop on g7 that's the whole point oh
yeah enter one movers he also has one
move us up his sleeve yeah of course
evergreen d3 was just a good move anyway
so it's not like it was a dirty trick or
anything I just blundered the pawn in
this in this position yeah okay
so let's go here
just trying to be be a bit active okay
other look we too would be cute if I get
this out but probably probably he'd
prevent that no he didn't ok let's go
there
let's get ready for entering with the
Queen and possible so if i go here
probably have to do that anyway yeah
Bishop g4 I thought
you should deform
I c-5m discovered attack on my rook that
might be might be on ya can not good not
good
I can take g6 as well check yep yeah
okay if it was resins very stupid just I
just blended g6 of course I don't think
this is so terrible white is better but
it's it's nothing nothing terrible Jam
and my main mistake is that I should
have played night f5 and then I'm just
okay nothing nothing going on I could
take you three them that's ok but not
that's not the main mistake of course
the main mistake was to him to actually
allow Queen g6 but but still now okay
maybe I should check their play 97 that
is still ok yeah but okay if I just play
let's say queen at five this is just not
much White has the better bishop but I
don't really know if you can avoid truck
trades on the e-file and then you never
win this never I can just I just forgot
about that that sometimes the problem
when you play against him is so reliable
in doing nothing that sometimes if he
actually does something you tend to
overlook it so on yeah SCD a queen d3
was just not a routine nothing move but
it was actually attacking g6 so I didn't
didn't pay attention here okay well
thanks for watching